On 15 December 2014, a lone wolf terrorist inspired by Islamic State walked into the Link Cafe in Sydney's Martin Place, armed with a pump-action shotgun, and the threat of a backpack bomb. Over 16 hours, he held 18 hostages captive in a siege that was live-streamed around the world. Tiger Tiger Tiger tells the untold story of the courageous actions of the New South Wales Tactical Operations Unit. This book will challenge what you thought you knew about the Lint siege, with details that show how willing the Tactical Operations Unit operators were to sacrifice their lives. But Tiger Tiger Tiger is more than an edge of your seat inside his perspective on Australia's first terrorist hostage rescue mission.
Written by the officer who shot and killed the terrorist, this extraordinary frontline account provides an insight into the psychological damage done in the line of duty. It offers a message of resilience and hope for everyone. Tiger, tiger, tiger had me gripped from start to end. I finished it in two days because I simply couldn't put it down. Visit tiger, tiger, tiger, book.com to grab your copy. That's tiger, tiger, tiger, book.com Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support,
please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. This episode was originally released on Casefile's Patreon, Apple Premium and Spotify Premium feeds as an early bonus for our paid subscribers. These episodes are designed to be slightly shorter, allowing us to cover a broader range of cases. To receive these episodes early and add free, you can support CaseFile on your preferred platform. Shortly before 3pm on Saturday, January 14, 2012, the doorbell rang at the Howe family home.
49-year-old Chun Num answered it. Standing on his doorstep was a teenage boy whom Chun Num didn't recognize. It seemed reasonable to assume he had come to see one of Chun Nams two children. When asked who he was looking for, the boy explained that he wanted to speak to Vinci. Vinci was Chun Nams 15-year-old daughter. Chun Nams called for Vinci, who appeared at the top of the staircase. She said she would speak with the boy. Chun Nam retreated to the kitchen to prepare dinner, leaving Vinci and her male gased alone.
Moments later, Chun Nam heard Vinci cry out in pain and he rushed back into the foyer. He was immediately struck in the face with a knife, leaving a bleeding gash across his right cheek. Chun Nam raised his hands for protection, while simultaneously trying to fly it off his assailant. The commotion alerted Chun Nam's 12-year-old son, who rushed in to find his father grappling with a teenage boy holding a knife. The teen managed to stab Chunnam several more times in the face, head and arms before
fleeing out the front door. Lying nearby at the base of the stairs was Vinci. Her face was covered in blood. Vinci Howe lived in the Dutch city of Arnhem. She was a popular secondary school student with an active social life and to many friends. In her spare time, Vinci visited herself with a variety of hobbies, including dancing for a street crew, learning piano, and playing chess. Vinci had adopted the western name Joyce, but her family still referred to her by her
Chinese heritage name Vinci. While she drew friends from diverse circles, Vinci mostly gravitated towards other teenagers of Chinese descent like her. Reports of the attack on Vinci and her father spread quickly online. Many of Vinci's friends learned of her ordeal through social media. As Vinci and Chun Nam were rushed to hospital, police worked swiftly to track down their attacker. Vince's brother was able to provide a description.
Several of the how family's neighbors had seen the blood soaked teen fleeing the area. Within two hours of the attack, police tracked the boy down to a street north of where the how's lived. He was hiding in some bushes and refused to give himself up. The police fired a single gunshot into the air as a warning, prompting the teen to surrender. The offender was a 14-year-old from Capell and Eiraisal, about two hours west of Varnam. As he was a minor at the time, he has never been fully publicly identified. In reports, he was only referred to as Yinhua K. Yinhua had been kicked out of school
five months earlier and already had a criminal record for two propertyences. Investigators determined that Yinhua and Vinci Hao were not France, but they were superficially acquainted. They shared the same social circles and were known to have attended at least one gathering together months earlier. A photograph taken at this party showed Yinhua pulling a funny face. Two girls stood on either side of him. One was Vinci Howe. Yin Hua eventually confessed to stabbing Vinci and her father. It took a while longer to establish why. Yin Hua finally admitted that the attack wasn't his idea.
He had been recruited to kill Vinci by a 17-year-old reported as Wesley C. Wesley was also Chinese Dutch and lived in Rotterdam. When interviewed, Wesley denied knowing Inwa or having any involvement in the attack. In all, neither Yinhua nor Wessley were particularly helpful to the police. Investigators combed through the two boys' social media, hoping to establish a connection between them.
They eventually came across a conversation between the pair on the telecommunications app, Skype. The day before Vinci and her father were attacked, Wesley and the Inua had exchanged a series of messages. Wesley told the Inua, tomorrow you will do it. Inua responded, okay man, is good. Wesley then provided Yinhua with specific instructions on how to carry out the stabbing before stating, you have the address, you know where to be. She has piano lessons at 2 p.m., so you have to go at 3 p.m. Yinhua responded, okay, if her parents are home, should I take them with me?
Wesley's final message, red. Yes, that's okay. Chun Num Hau recovered from his injuries and was released from hospital, but his daughter was in a dire state. Vinci had sustained several deep stubwurns to her face and knack. Five days after the attack, she died. The next day, 600 mourners marched through the city silently alongside Vinci's family in a show of support. The route took them past the house home,
where a large collection of flowers and soft toys had been placed in honor of Vinci. At the end of the march, a representative of the house family thanked the crowd. Vinci's murder was described by her loved ones as incomprehensible. They asked, how could boys aged 14 and 17 without any relation to Finzi commit such a heinous act on an innocent and defenseless 15-year-old
girl? What could be the motive? The family also made it clear that in these circumstances they viewed Dutch punishment for juveniles as inadequate. They called for Yinhua and Wesley to be tried as adults, stating that anyone who could commit such a bloody and premeditated act of violence was no longer a child. The following weekend, Vinci's friends hold a small gathering of their own. They let Chinese lanterns and released them into the night sky. One of the attendees filmed part of the service. The footage captured Vinci's 16-year-old best friend, Polly, saying goodbye to Vinci.
But it was the tone of her voice that stood out. Instead of speaking with sadness, Polly sounded noticeably gleeful. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. I am excited to announce the launch of Unfiltered, the latest podcast from Case File Presents. Unfiltered has been in the works for a long time now. It will be hosted by Raquel O'Brien, whose extraordinary podcast, Silent Waves, was the first show released on the case for our Presents Platform. After getting to know Raquel
and seeing how talented she is at interviewing people for more walks of life, I knew that she had to have her own conversation style podcast, and thus unfiltered was born. A podcast that provides an exploration into human experiences. No topic is off limits. These raw and honest conversations will open you up to a range of perspectives and invite you to make up your own mind. Although I don't host the show, unfiltered has several tie-ins with CaseFile. The first episode features the first in-depth interview I've ever given. It's a long chat, and you'll get to know some things about me that I've never spoken about publicly.
Recurl is the only person I felt comfortable having this conversation with. The second episode stars two key witnesses from Case 78 of Case File, the Janabi family. Former US soldier Justin White and his former sergeant John Deem joined Recull to speak about their experiences in war and what it was like to blow the whistle on war crimes. Future episodes feature a diverse range of guests from all walks of life. Some are connected to case file episodes or one of our case file presents series, while others are completely unrelated. But all feature real stories about justice and transformation.
The first two episodes, including my interview, are available now, wherever you get your podcasts, with all subsequent episodes to be released weekly. Be sure to hit the follow button for Unfiltered, so you don't miss an episode. Hey everybody, this is Jake Johnson. And Garrett Reynolds. And we're inviting you to listen to our new podcast we're here to help. Yeah, we're an advice podcast where people call in with their problems and we try to help. We try, we can't stress this enough, we are not professionals and we're not even very good at this.
So take our advice and listen to we're here to help, wherever you listen to podcasts. We got it! Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. On a November night, eight weeks before Vinzie Howe was attacked, she attended a party at a local pool center with her best friend, Polly. During the course of the evening, Vinzie became increasingly irritated at Polly's behavior. She felt Polly was being flirtatious and conceded with her new boyfriend, Wesley.
Vinci vented about this to some of the other girls in her friendship circle. When Polly caught wind of Vinci's complaints, an argument broke out between them. Everyone at the party saw the fight. It started with the pair shouting and swearing at each other before turning physical. Eventually, the two girls were pulled apart and they went their separate ways. Days later, Polly posted something on her Facebook page that Vinci took issue with. When Vinci's comment, though one of their mutual friends replied, Vinci, you have to be careful how you talk and you better learn from your mistakes.
Another friend wrote, Make Vinci stop because otherwise something serious will happen. While Polly didn't display any animosity towards Vinci online, offline she was seething. Although their friendship group was divided, many ultimately took Polly's side. She told her boyfriend Wesley that she hated Viny and wanted her out of her life. Despite having only just started dating Polly a few weeks prior, Wesley threw his support behind her. He encouraged his girlfriend's anger.
A week after the party, Polly and Wesley composed a threatening text message which they sent to Vincey via Wesley's mobile phone. Vinci's reply to Wesley's text further enraged Polly. With the conflict escalating, Vinci's mother called Polly's mother to address the issue. They discussed Polly's behaviour, but their conversation had no impact on the conflict. Police anger soon reached boiling point. She informed her boyfriend that she wanted Vinci gone for good. Wesley suggested they find someone who could kill Vinci on their behalf.
The following weekend, Wesley and Polly went to a party in Arnhem. Polly spoke openly of how she wanted Vinci dead, but none of the party goers wanted to confront her about it. If they did, it could ruin the night. So they brushed their concerns off, refusing to take police threats seriously. To keep the peace, they made sure not to invite Vinci to the party. She showed up anyway. Polly was furious.
She confronted Vinci, called her derogatory names, pushed her and yelled, I'll kill you and I'll kill your family. Vinci was in tears. She seemed to genuinely shocked at the way her former best friend was now behaving towards her. Worse still, most of the pair's mutual friends continued to side with Polly, despite her increasingly volatile behavior. They were more upset that Vinci had ruined the party by attending. In the days that followed, Polly stepped up her campaign against Vinci.
Almost daily she bombarded her with death threats via text messages and social media. Vinci spent most of her time on the computer in her room, trying to seem unaffected and defiant in retorts she sent back to Polly. In reality, Vinci was growing increasingly fearful that Polly might follow through on her threats. But none of the pair's friends shared her concerns. One later spoke to Dutch Karen Affairs Program in Newseer, saying that she and everyone else in their friendship group
thought that police threats against Vinci had been empty. Polly was known for having an explosive personality and aggressive style of speaking. Even Vinci's parents had dismissed the issue, assuming it was just typical teenage bickering that was being blown out of proportion. Vinci's father, Chun Nam, told Newsyear that he believed the feud would fizzle out, and Vinci and Polly would become friends again. In actuality, Polly had started hatching her revenge less than a month after the fight began. Her boyfriend Wesley knew of a 14-year-old named Yinhua who was known to carry a knife.
Wesley was confident that Yinhua would do almost anything to gain his favour. He was right. When asked, Yinhua agreed to kill Vinci Hau. Just over two weeks later on Christmas Day, Polly and Wesley met up with the Yinhua at a snack bar in a village south of Rotterdam. There, the trio began planning Vinci's murder. Inwara had attempted to recruit others to participate in the slaughter, but hadn't found anyone willing to commit.
He resolved that he would carry out the murder himself. Polly promised to pay Yinhua. While the final amount offered for the killing has never been confirmed, it was believed that it was somewhere between 50 to 100 euros, around 70 to 150 Australian dollars. Wesley also promised he would shut Yinhua drinks whenever they attended the same parties. Wesley and Yinhua kept in touch over the next few days, either in person, by phone or online, as they ironed out the details. Polly was either present for or aware of all these interactions.
At first, it was decided that Yinhua would kill Vinci within the next few days. However, they decided to put their plans on hold until the new year. A week later, on Friday, January 6, 2012, Wesley handed Yinhua a piece of paper. On it, Polly had written the How Families Address, along with specific directions on how to get to the home via public transport. She'd even provided a description of the cartoon character decals on the glass next to Vinci's front door and the paintflex on the pavement in front. One week later, Polly called one of Vinci's classmates to find out what time Vinci would
be home from school that day. Wesley was present when his girlfriend made the call and passed the details on to Yin Hua. Yin Hua was already in Anum, waiting on Vinci's street. Our was passed, but Vinci never appeared. Frustrated, Yinhua gave up and left. Upon discovering that Vinci had not been killed as planned, Polly was furious. She insisted that Wesley contact Yinhua to organize another date for the murder. At about 9 the following evening, Wesley messaged Yunhua via Skype.
He confirmed that Vinci's parents would be acceptable collateral damage and set 3pm as the time of the attack. Police stood over her boyfriend as he typed, tomorrow you will do it. On the afternoon of Saturday, January 14, Yinhua traveled back to Vinci's house. He spoke to Wesley several times over the phone during the 90-minute journey. Wesley was with Polly and the two provided Yinhua Wesley several times over the phone during the 90 minute journey. Wesley was with Polly and the two provided Yenwa with encouragement to follow through
with the plan. It was nearing 3pm when Yenwa reached the three-story red brick terrace house belonging to the Hau family. The cartoon stickers on the window were alongside the blue front door and the white paint splattered on the pavement confirmed that Yinhua was at the right place. He approached the door and was led inside before attacking Vinci. When her father attempted to step in, Yinhua stabbed him too. After Polly's involvement in Vinci's murder was established, she was arrested. As with Yin Hua and Wesley, Polly was only referred to publicly by her
first name and to last initial, Polly W. Yin Hua was charged with Vinci's murder and the attempted manslaughter of her father, Chun Num Hau. Polly and Wesley were both charged with intentional incitement to murder. All three teens were held in juvenile detention while they awaited trial. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. I am excited to announce the launch of Unfiltered, the latest podcast from Case File Presents. Unfiltered has been in the works for a long time now. It will be hosted by Raquel O'Brien, whose extraordinary podcast, Silent Waves,
was the first show released on the Casefile Presents platform. After getting to know Raquel and seeing how talented she is at interviewing people from all walks of life, I knew that she had to have her own conversation style podcast, and thus unfiltered was born. A podcast that provides an exploration into human experiences. No topic is off limits. These raw and honest conversations will open you up to a range of perspectives and invite you to make up your own mind Although I don't host the show unfiltered has several tie-ins with case file The first episode features the first in-depth interview I've ever given It's a long chat and you'll get to know some things about me that I've never spoken about publicly Recall is the only person I felt comfortable having this conversation with.
The second episode stars two key witnesses from Case 78 of Case File, the Janabi family. Former US soldier Justin Wat and his former sergeant John Deem joined Rikkel to speak about their experiences in war and what it was like to blow the whistle on war crimes. Future episodes feature a diverse range of guests from all walks of life. Some are connected to case file episodes or one of our case file presents series, while others are completely unrelated. But all feature real stories about justice and transformation. real stories about justice and transformation. The first two episodes, including my interview, are available now wherever you get your podcasts, with all subsequent episodes to be released weekly. Be sure to hit the follow button for Unfiltered,
so you don't miss an episode. Hey everybody this is Jake Johnson and Garrett Reynolds. And we're inviting you to listen to our new podcast. We're here to help. Yeah, we're an advice podcast where people call in with their problems and we try to help. We try. We can't stress this enough. We are not professionals and we're not even very good at this.
So take our advice and listen to we're here to help. Wherever you listen to podcasts. We got it! Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. Yinhua K was the first of the three accused to be tried. His court proceedings began in August 2012, 7-months-safeter Vinci's murder. In the Netherlands, cases against mine as are usually heard behind closed doors. However, in Inwars case, the panel of three judges made the rare decision to conduct an open hearing. They determined that the public interest outweighed Inwars' individual rights.
In relation to Vinci's murder, Inwai pleaded not guilty by reason of diminished responsibility. His defence council relied on two expert psychological reports. A specialist child and adolescent psychologist concluded that Inwai suffered from a serious behavioural disorder and psychopathic traits. The second report submitted by a panel of clinical psychologists stated that Yinhua placed extreme importance on fitting in with his peers. This man didn't even consider refusing Polly and Wesley's demands. In Yinhua's mind, killing Vinci was a guaranteed part to social acceptance.
Both reports concluded that In Wai should be regarded as having diminished responsibility on account of his defective mental, emotional and social development. The Defence Council also attempted to limit In Wai's responsibility by citing the extreme external pressure placed on him by Polly and Wesley. The defense claimed that Polly and Wesley threatened to kill Yinhua's parents if he did not do as they instructed. The court found no evidence to support these allegations, and concluded that Yinhua was a willing participant in the attacks. and concluded that Yin Wai was a willing participant in the attacks.
They were also satisfied that Yin Wai's actions were pre-meditated and not a spur of the moment decision made while Yin Wai was in a quote, blacked out state, as his lawyers had suggested. Yin Wai also pleaded not guilty to the attempted manslaughter of Chun Nam Ham-Hao. He maintained that he'd only defended himself from Chun-Nam, who attacked him. The court also rejected this claim, as Yin-Wa instigated the violent altercation with the Chun-Nam, and consciously chose to keep hold of his knife as he did so. The Skype correspondence between Yin-Wa and Wesley the day prior to the attack only further
discredited Yin-Wa's claims. He had specifically asked if he should also kill Vinci's parents if they interfered and was told to do so. In his victim impact statement, Chun Nam-He spoke of how his life had turned into hell since the murder of his daughter. He also bore the physical scars of his life or death struggle with Vinci's killer. Chunnam implored the court to find Yinhua guilty and to sentence him as an adult rather than a juvenile.
Vinci's mother wasn't home at the time her daughter was set upon and has lived with that guilt ever since. Let suspects of this horrific act to get their deserved punishment, she told the court. The judges delivered their verdict two weeks later. In Waqe was found guilty for both the murder of Vinzi Hao and the attempted manslaughter of Chun Num Hao. As Yinhua was only 14 when he committed these crimes, Dutch laws for juvenile offenders applied.
These laws focused strongly on rehabilitation rather than punishment. As such, Inwai was sentenced to one year in juvenile detention and a further three years in a TBS. TBS is a criminal psychiatric facility where offenders received psychological and psychiatric counseling to help reintegrate them into society. This sentence was the maximum term permitted under Dutch law at the time. Chunnam-Hao called Yin-Wa's punishment offensive and urged politicians to consider revising the sentencing laws for exceptional cases such as this.
Polly W and Wesley C both pleaded not guilty to intentionally inciting Yinhua to murder Vinci. Through her lawyer, Polly claimed that her wish for Vinci to die was not meant to be taken literally. She said it was just a turn of phrase that was common in Chinese culture. However, no evidence was provided to prove this. Two psychological reports were submitted, with experts determining that Poly suffered from a delay in social-emotional development, identity problems, and a behavioral disorder.
Polly flatly denied threatening or incentivizing Inwata kill Vinci. The court rejected these arguments, finding ample evidence that Polly intended for Vinci to be killed. Wesley's defense argued there was no evidence that messages sent from Wesley's phone and social media were actually written by Wesley. They claimed that Polly was responsible for them instead. Wesley was depicted as a love struck teen who allowed Polly to have complete control over him. Wesley claimed that he hadn't wanted Vinci dead, he just wanted to scare her. Two psychological reports suggested that Wesley functioned at the intellectual and emotional
level of an 11-year-old. They also indicated that Wesley had an overdependence and attachment to his mother, which transferred to Polly once they started dating. The court determined that there was close and conscious collaboration between Polly and Wesley in provoking Vinci's murder. Both teens were found guilty. The court stated that it was shocking and hard to comprehend that a seemingly trivial
quarrel between two young girls could turn a friendship into deep hatred and eventually lead to murder. The prosecution called for both Polly and Wesley to be sentenced as adults. This was permissible in exceptional cases where juvenile offenders were at least 16 years old. The court acknowledged the seriousness of the offences and the indescribable impact that Binsie's murder had on her family and the community. However, given Polly and Wesley's delayed emotional and intellectual development, the court determined that their sentence
should focus primarily on rehabilitation, rather than retaliation. Polley and Wesley were sentenced to two years in juvenile detention, the maximum permissible under Dutch juvenile sentencing laws. Before they were eligible to be released back into society, the pair would be required to spend a time in a TBS. Polly would face three years in the TBS and Wesley too. The public prosecutor appealed these sentences, pushing again for polyand Wesley to be sentenced as adults. Both appeals were rejected. Wesley C was released in February 2017. A probation report explained that Wesley's emotional immaturity and attachment issues were treated through psychotherapy and behavioral
interventions. The report also indicated that Wesley's socio-emotional disadvantages had been rectified, and that his self-insight had dramatically improved. His risk of recidivism was judged to be low. PolyW was released two weeks later. Polly's probation report indicated that she no longer suffered from a conduct or identity disorder, and no personality disorder had developed. Her risk of recidivism was judged to be low as long as she continued counseling. As a condition of their release, neither Polly nor Wesley were permitted to contact each other.
Both were required to continue psychological counselling and report regularly to authorities during their probation period. During this time, Yinhua K applied for release. The court determined that although he had undergone positive development, a few incidents had arisen during his rehabilitation where he made inappropriate choices. Concerns remained as to Yinhua's ability to appropriately deal with frustrations. Accordingly, he was ordered to remain in TBS. Inwa submitted a second application seven months later.
His risk of recurrence was noted as low to moderate, primarily in relation to his impulsive behavior, lack of empathy, and insufficient cooperation with certain TBS interventions. However, the court found that Yinhua exhibited a less risky behavior, had demonstrated an ability to withstand disappointments and manage responsibilities, and showed a willingness to seek help. The court determined that he no longer posed a serious risk of violent crime. Rejecting the public prosecutor's request to further extend Yinhua's custody arrangements, the court approved Yinhua's release in September 2017, subject to stringent conditions. Yinhua was required to regularly report to probation services, refrain from drug and alcohol use,
follow a strict daily routine, and grant authorities access to his social media accounts and finances. In April of the following year, an advertisement appeared online for the sale of several expensive pieces of computer equipment. The seller, whom Casefile will refer to as Mark, was contacted by an interested buyer. Two men arrived at Mark's house that evening. Mark told the telegraph newspaper that he opened the door to two neat looking and friendly men of East Asian appearance, presumably a father and son. The two men collected the computer equipment.
Instead of handing over the agreed 4,000 euros as payment, the older of the man pulled out a gun and pointed it directly at Mark's head. The young man ordered Mark onto his knees and instructed him to count to 60 before moving. He threatened to shoot Mark, his girlfriend, and their baby, if Mark attempted anything as the men were leaving. After Mark was certain they had driven away, he called the police. It took the police a few weeks before they had the two armed robbers in custody. The younger one was Yanhua K. News of Yanhua's violent re-offending brought pain to Chunnam-Hao, who was still coming to
terms with the loss of his daughter. He told the telegraph, I am not at all surprised that Yin Hua has made a mistake again. He is severely disturbed that was evident from the murder. Chun Nam further commented, I like the idea that Yinhua is now in jail. I hope for myself and for society that Yinhua stays inside forever. During the investigation into Vinci House murder, investigators examined online and phone records of Yinhua, Polly, Wesley and their friends.
They soon realized that the murder plot wasn't a well-kept secret between the three involved. In fact, many other youths were well aware of it. Two hours before Vinci was attacked, a friend of Yinhua's posted on Facebook. A girl is going to die at 3pm today. 19 minutes later, at 123, the post received its first response. The user wrote, Oh my god. Yet, no one called the police. The post remained up long after Vininci and her father had been struck.
One user responded to the post about an hour and a half after the attack, writing, Whoa, I just saw it on the newsman. Damn. Just over an hour after that, another user responded to the post with a warning that read, Watch out! The police also have Facebook. Many more of Polly and Vinci's friends were aware of the plot since its inception.
One of Vinci's friends told a news year, If everyone who knew about it, who should have reported something but didn't, then I think that 60 people should be arrested for being complicit. You know, because everyone knew about it. Everyone knew about it. Ultimately, no one who remained silent while knowing that Vinci was in danger was charged with any crimes. I am excited to announce the launch of Unfiltered, the latest podcast from CaseFile Presents. Unfiltered has been in the works
for a long time now. It will be hosted by Rikello Bryan, whose extraordinary podcast, Silent Waves, was the first show released on the Casefile Presents platform. After getting to know Rikell and seeing how talented she is at interviewing people from all walks of life, I knew that she had to have her own conversation style podcast, and thus unfiltered was born. A podcast that provides an exploration into human experiences. No topic is off limits. These raw and honest conversations will open you up to a range of perspectives and invite you to make up your own mind.
Although I don't host the show, unfiltered has several tie-ins with CaseFile. The first episode features the first in-depth interview I've ever given. It's a long chat and you'll get to know some things about me that I've never spoken about publicly. Rekal is the only person I felt comfortable having this conversation with. The second episode stars two key witnesses from Case 78 of Case File, the Janabi family. Former US soldier Justin Wat and his former sergeant John Deem joined Rikkel to speak about their experiences in war and what it was like to blow the whistle on war crimes.
Future episodes feature a diverse range of guests from all walks of life. Some are connected to case file episodes or one of our case file presents series, while others are completely unrelated. But all feature real stories about justice and transformation. real stories about justice and transformation. The first two episodes, including my interview, are available now wherever you get your podcasts, with all subsequent episodes to be released weekly. Be sure to hit the follow button for unfiltered, so you don't miss an episode. On 15 December 2014, a lone wolf terrorist inspired by Islamic State walked into the link cafe in Sydney's Martin Place, armed with a pump-action shotgun, and the threat of a backpack bomb. Over 16 hours, he held 18 hostages captive in a siege that was live-streamed around the world.
18 hostages captive in a siege that was live streamed around the world. Tiger Tiger Tiger tells the untold story of the courageous actions of the New South Wales Tactical Operations Unit. This book will challenge what you thought you knew about the Lint siege, with details that show how willing the tactical operations unit operators were to sacrifice their lives. But Tiger Tiger Tiger is more than an edge of your seat inside his perspective on Australia's first terrorist hostage rescue mission. Written by the officer who shot and killed the terrorist, this extraordinary frontline account provides an insight into the psychological damage done in the line of duty. It offers a message of resilience and hope for everyone.
Tiger, tiger, tiger had me gripped from start to end. I finished it in two days because I simply couldn't put it down. Visit tiger, tiger, tiger, book.com to grab your copy. That's tiger, tiger, tiger, book.com That's Tyga Tyga Book. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.